nos dicen usa una estimación para decir
si cada cociente estimado es razonable o
no es razonable y tenemos un grupo de
cocientes estimados por aquí por ejemplo
alguien estima que dos mil 419 dividido
entre tres es aproximadamente igual a
7500 y habrá que elegir si nos parece
razonable o no después tenemos otros dos
cocientes estimados para decir si nos
parecen razonables o no así que pausa el
vídeo e inténtalo antes de trabajarlo
juntos bien vamos a trabajar juntos y la
forma de resolverlo será hacer la
estimación por mi cuenta así que
empezaré por la primera tengo dos mil
419 entre tres y bueno una forma de
estimar será pensar en un número cercano
que sea más fácil de calcular algunos
dicen un número más amigable de calcular
3 es un número simple muy amigable y
2.419 es un número un poco más
complicado pero puedo preguntarme si
existe algún múltiplo de 3 cercano a 2
mil 419 que sea un número amigable bueno
sabemos que 3 por 8 24 así que algo como
24 veces 100 es lo mismo que 2400 bueno
esto será más fácil de dividir entre 3
así que puedo decir que esto es
aproximadamente igual a 2400 entre 3 lo
único que dije fue oye 2419 para
propósitos de hacer una estimación vamos
a decir que es aproximadamente igual a
2400 y 2400 es muy sencillo de dividir
entre 3 y 24 entre 3 es 8
entonces esto de aquí es 24 veces 100
entre 3 es decir ocho veces 100 y 800
por lo tanto dos mil 419 dividido entre
tres es aproximadamente igual a 800 y si
nos fijamos nos dicen que esto es
aproximadamente igual a 7500 y eso es
mucho más que 800 si nos dijeran 750
bueno tal vez sería razonable pero si
nos dicen 7500 es un poco menos que 10
veces 800 así que en definitiva puedo
decir que esto no es razonable
bueno ahora vamos al segundo cociente
pero una vez más pausa el vídeo y ver si
puedes encontrar la respuesta bien voy a
intentar estimar de nuevo el cociente de
435 entre 5 vamos a decir que esto es
aproximadamente igual a bueno un
múltiplo de 5 que se acerca fácilmente a
435 de nuevo estoy pensando en un número
amigable es 400 así que puedo decir que
esto es aproximadamente igual a 400
entre 5 y sabemos que 40 entre 5 es 8
entonces 40 decenas divididas entre 5 es
lo mismo que 8 decenas y 80 así que esto
será igual a 80 o lo puedes pensar de
otra manera 5 por 8 decenas son 40
decenas que es 400 es lo mismo así que
esta división si es aproximadamente
igual a 80 que es lo que nosotros
estimamos así que nos parece razonable
muy bien hagamos el último pausa el
vídeo de nuevo e inténtalo
bien tengo 6202 dividido entre 2 puedo
decir que esto es casi igual a
aproximadamente igual a am bueno si
quiero hacer esto muy aproximado en
lugar de 6.200 2 usemos 6000 para hacer
las cosas muy sencillas ahora seis veces
1000 entre 2 es 3 veces mil o 3 mil pero
aquí tenemos 300 eso es una décima parte
de lo que estimamos así que no no es
razonable y ya está hemos acabado